[music]
[singing]
>> If you guys want to get your shirt, it's
available right now. All you got to do
is go to godlogicclothing.com.
The link is in the description. So we
can all be rocking the woods. What's
what what's in the beat?
>> [music]
>> What's going on everyone? I am here
sitting with David Wood himself. What's
going on, man? Tick tock. Time
[laughter] to rock.
>> Time to rock, baby.
Now the guys, this is Mike Winger, man.
And Mike, let me just say, dude,
when it comes to my growth in my
spiritual walk and my apologetics like
upbringing, you are one of the core
parts of that. With your ministry, your
breakdowns. Um how often do you get this
when it's like uh this up-and-coming
guys are telling you, "Hey, man, you are
one of those ones." You know.
>> [laughter]
>> I don't know I don't know. I mean, I
don't know if it's even cool to say, but
but it's it's thrilling because I mean,
I really do try to shape my ministry so
that it's training people. It's not just
informing them because I I think the
people who are really following my
content, they're using it, you know. And
they're not just using it by rote.
They're like learning skills and
developing tactics. And then to the
point where they'll be like, "I don't
really need that guy so much because I
can do this." And I'm like, "That's the
real That's the real big goal. Oh, yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah, for for people to
become masters of what you're teaching
them, what you're giving them. Getting
them good at theology, good at
apologetics, good at digging in the word
verse by verse, understanding it. And
then good at like
handling contrary opinions and stuff
like that. Yeah, This this was something
that I wondered, Mike, cuz you know, um
what is it that got you into
specifically the field that you do?
Like, you know, you have Christian
internet, you got the you know,
basically you got the charismatics that
you know, that's really about you know,
kind of spiritual walk and you can do
this in Christ. You got the debaters,
you got the apologetics. You're kind of
like you have apologetics in it, you
have teaching, you know, how to what
made you go into the field and tailor it
to how you
you kind of kind of have your own thing
honestly.
>> I guess so.
Well, I mean I [clears throat] kind of
did what I thought I was good at. Mhm.
Or what I thought I was best at. However
good you are, you know, I did focus on
that and figured if I'm going to do
ministry online, I'll just do whatever I
think I'm best at and then we'll see if
it helps people and then it just worked.
But apologetics I got into because of my
own questions, you know, so I'm
wrestling with my own questions and I
would ask people around me and
people who weren't apologetics minded
>> Yeah, yeah, yeah. And it was like I
realized like they're not ready for my
questions, you know, [laughter]
and it was like this isn't even healthy
for them. So I just did deep dives like
how do I know this about the Bible? How
do I know this about Jesus? How do I
know this? How do I know? How do I know?
And once I got the answers for myself,
you just sort of start becoming a go-to
source for other people
and then you'll see someone struggling
and you'll be like, "Hey man, I've been
there."
And you can give those answers out. So
that that was incorporated into my
teaching pastoral ministry
and I became like the the source at the
church for people like that.
>> Did you have like go-tos like so like
for you know, for me like I told you,
you were one of them, Sam Shamoun, David
Wood, you know, folks like Jeff Durbin,
you know, I had guys that I that did all
that hard work already and is now
teaching it. Did you have go-tos for
you?
That's a good question.
There's a number of people I'd listen to
for apologetic stuff.
I found William Lane Craig's stuff to be
really helpful, truly helpful. I would
do I would listen to debates all the
time, Mhm. the time. So whoever's out
there doing debates and getting their
hands dirty and stuff like that,
>> Yeah. I listen because I wanted to hear
the counterpoints. Yeah. Now, of course,
when I'm doing this, like, nowadays,
it's easy to find the counterpoints, but
10, 15, 20 years ago, it was not so
easy.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Um so, you you want to you
like look for those debates and those
arguments and stuff cuz I want to hear
I don't want to be ambushed by an
objection I couldn't think of.
>> Yeah. I want to know the best objection
to my position
>> Yeah. so that I can make sure it's true.
Yeah.
>> Because I can't even with integrity
present it unless I do that. And you
know, you've had times where you're
you're wrong about something.
>> Yeah. Absolutely.
>> like stick your your face out there and
you're like, "Well, this." And then
someone's like, "Oh, yeah? Blah, blah,
blah." and you go, "Oh."
Why didn't I think about that?
>> [laughter]
>> You know, so They got me there. So, you
have a bunch of stuff. Like, I listen to
a lot of debates, a lot of those
discussions. Um
different resources. And then I I
started doing research where I wouldn't
have like one source because no one guy
goes that deep on that many issues.
>> Yeah. So, I just started doing like deep
dives where I'm
looking at as many sources as I can. You
know, trying to coalesce it into like
one teachable video or something where I
kind of bring it all together. Yeah.
Very good. One of the one of the videos
that has stuck with me for Well, he was
kind of doing a series on like um
Bible reliability. You were going over
um textual variances. You were even
breaking down um different translations
and, you know, so uh for for me, it was
like, "Okay, you helped me get a a
better understanding of or even a a
perspective of how to look at
translations of the Bible and how to
look at textual variances. What which
ones matter, which ones don't, and how
do we look at the ones that matter and
stuff like that. Yeah. So, when you have
videos that stick with people that till
this day, I'm telling you, in my
apologetics, I use in my teaching, I
use.
>> That's awesome.
>> So,
for you, do you have you do you pay
attention to the apologetics world a
little bit? The debates? Have you been
Are you in the mix a little bit there?
>> I So, I love that stuff.
>> Yeah. I find myself really busy.
>> [laughter]
>> So, I try. I try to track with it. I
can't track with it as well as well as I
used to in the past.
>> Because the work I'm focused on isn't
related to some of that, so I can't um
But I remember that like uh yeah, those
that textual variant stuff. I dug deep
on that stuff
for my own sake initially. Uh-huh. Um
but it it broke me out of like a almost
a King James only-ish kind of view
before I even had a YouTube channel.
>> Yeah.
Yeah.
>> And uh and made me realize like I was I
was around people who'd be like, "The
NIV's the not inspired version."
>> Mhm. That's what NIV stands for.
>> [laughter]
>> And I did I did I dug deep and I went,
"I'm so relieved to know this. This is
not true."
You know, that oh man, we got
you know, but it's complicated because
there are variants and we should discuss
them.
So, yeah. I I I do try to keep aware. I
know you've been debating a lot and
>> Yeah, I've been kind of busy myself.
>> And you And from what I heard, you've
been really like successful at it. Like
you're you're you're you're really
successfully You know, when uh when Paul
went and debated in the synagogue,
people don't know this about the
debates. I don't know why they don't
know this. It seems the most obvious
thing. They don't know
the debate's not for the debaters. It's
for the audience.
>> Exactly. Exactly.
>> Yeah, yeah. You're not actually trying
to change the mind of that guy.
>> Exactly.
>> In fact, having a public debate makes it
less likely he'll change his mind cuz
he's going to dig his heels in. His
ego's on the line.
>> of eyes are on him. You're doing it to
change the mind of the audience. So,
like Paul goes in and he's arguing in
the synagogues
and he converts people to Christ. But
not the leaders.
>> Not the Yeah, not the leaders.
>> [laughter]
>> They boot him out of there. Yeah, no,
that is that is so important because
man, you'll
the comments that I get sometimes it's
like mixed. I get comments that are
like, "Man, why is Avery" For example,
here's a beautiful example. There's a
Muslim named Junior, okay? Oh, I'm I'm a
little bit familiar with Junior. He's a
He's a Bless his heart.
>> Yeah.
>> [laughter]
>> And we pray for Junior. This dude here,
right?
We had a debate with him. I I brought
brought him onto my channel. And
the comments like people in the live
chat while we're debating, this dude is
so below Avery's tier. Why is Avery even
debating him? Why is Avery even giving
him the time? He's wasting his time,
right? In the Q&A,
there was a a woman. Her name is Layla.
I'm assuming she sent the super chat.
She actually was on the channel before
asking questions and she was a Muslim.
>> Yeah. She sent the super chat and said,
"Hey Avery, I hope that you remember me.
I came on asking questions. After this
debate, I've seen how dishonest Junior
was. I've seen you break it down and
this is it for me. I'm I'm making the
decision to leave Islam. I would like to
if you can, can you break down more of
the Trinity so that I can better
comprehend and understand it?" During
the debate, Amen.
That's awesome. How many admission do we
get of that? We don't. Like God how God
orchestrates this. It's for them. I'm
not trying to convert Junior. Well, that
so like here the tier argument. Like you
should only debate people who are in the
same tier as you. I'm like, what are you
talking about?
>> Yeah. Yeah. I don't care about any of
that. I care about these people right
here.
What debate is going to help them come
to Jesus?
>> Exactly. What debate is going to take
what what they actually believe. So
sometimes you can debate a scholar
who's like knows his stuff about Islam
all this stuff and nobody knows his his
him and no none of the people who you're
trying to help. Yeah. They don't even
understand the guy.
>> Yeah. They don't know his arguments.
That guy doesn't change their minds,
right? You know who does? Zakir Naik. He
changes their minds. Yeah. You want to
face that guy because this guy it's
going to help the people the most.
>> Exactly.
>> So I don't care what level or tier
they're on. Exactly. It's evangelism.
That's what it is.
>> Yeah. It's evangelism. It's ministry.
And so what with with these
conversations, the listeners are being
equipped. They're being built up and
man, the the the amount of Christians
and this is what is encouraging. The
Christians be like, "Man, you made me
want to read the Bible more. Man, you
made me fall in love with Jesus more. I
was I was uh what do you call it
when you kind of backslide? Yeah, I was
backsliding but then I ran into your
video, saw you giving the gospel to the
Muslims and debating them. It made me on
fire for Jesus. Like that right there is
like this is why we're doing this.
Equipping the saints and bringing
non-believers to Christ and to think
about Jesus differently. You know, so
>> Yeah, that's that's what I do. Dude,
evangelism was part debate rather was
part of evangelism in the
>> Yes. Yes. Jesus debated the Pharisees
and the scribes, right? Paul debated the
Jews in the synagogues. Apollos debated
the Jews in the synagogues. You have him
go on Athens and he's like arguing a
case
>> Yeah. for the God of creation versus
these idols. And I think that that's
you're you're you're walking in a
biblical tradition when you do debate.
And
I think that there's great value in it.
We need We need some debaters in the
body of Christ.
>> 100% agree. Which leads me to my next
question, okay?
When it comes to the cults of the world
that we engage with, what would you say
off the top of your head
might be
the
probably the most underrated cult that
people kind of don't really pay
attention to but maybe need to start
paying attention to it.
If you had to If you had to pick
something.
I know I put you on the spot there.
>> [laughter]
>> That's a good question. I haven't looked
at numbers recently. Mhm. Um
the things that I would want to worry
about the most are the cults that are
growing the fastest.
>> Okay. And the cults that are
um
uh
especially in their earlier stages cuz I
think it's easier to stop them early on.
This is So I did I did a video on them
or a few videos on the Mother God cult.
Okay. Yes.
>> I call them the Mother God cult. They
don't call themselves that obviously,
right? They call [clears throat]
themselves a World Mission Society
Church of God.
But but they change their name
occasionally. And I was worried they
would change their name after my video
went out.
And I thought, "No, I'm going to give
them I'll give them a name."
>> Yeah. The Mother God Cult.
>> [laughter]
>> So, the Mother God Cult. You know, they
come up to you and they go, "Uh hey, uh
have you heard of God the Mother?" Yes.
>> That's That's their opening line when
they evangelize. And then you go,
"What?" And they go, "Well, we have a
You have a earthly father, don't you?
And an earthly mother. So, we have a
heavenly father and a heavenly And it
turns out God the Mother is like an
80-year-old Korean woman in South Korea
named Zahng Gil-jah. And it's But,
here's the weird thing about it.
>> Come on, bro. This cult This cult was
growing In In fact, it still is. It's
growing very, very fast. And they're
aggressive. And they seek out wealthy
Westerners is a target a target for them
cuz they want to bring the money in.
>> Yeah. They devastate people's lives.
They're very, very harmful.
It's false gospel. Yeah.
>> theology. Yeah.
>> But, they were growing at a faster rate.
And there was almost nothing available
on them. Where I was like, "Mormonism,
which is growing at a rate of like Yeah.
>> [laughter]
>> It's growing at the rate of your
grandma. And [laughter]
um
you know, we have tons of resources on
them.
>> [snorts]
>> You know, and it's still worth talking
about cuz especially locally, we have
lots of Mormons that we want to see them
come to Jesus, right?
>> Yeah. Yeah. But, uh this this South
Korean cult is going international.
They're growing really quick. So, the
Mother God Cult is one example of one
that I think like, "Hey, that We should
have more resources on them." So, I made
resources and others have as well. Like,
it's really So, did are they resources
that are physically accessible or just
videos? So, I um I did video resources.
There's also physical on um examining
the
I think I think the website is examining
the WMS CEO World Mission Society Church
of God, like, you know, acronyms.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> examiningthem.com.
I think that's what it is. But, there's
there's actually physical resources. I
do have stuff, but they are very
litigious.
>> Yeah. Okay.
>> So, I would like to put the books, the
rare books that I've got like in I just
like to put them on the online, but it
would absolutely sue me. Yeah, yeah,
yeah.
>> Um so they're [laughter] very litigious.
They had one of my videos removed off
YouTube.
>> They did?
>> Yeah, yeah. So I made one of I made a
longer one.
>> [laughter]
>> Oh, well, I see there there you go.
Remove this one, I'll make a longer one.
>> [laughter]
>> How's that sound?
>> That's freaking awesome. How how I got
into this stuff, man, is I got cooked by
Jehovah's Witnesses. I was like 20 years
old. They was on the college campus.
>> by who? Jehovah's Witnesses. Okay. Yeah.
>> Yeah. Yeah, yeah, yeah. I I went up to
them. I was like, "Man, let me ask some
questions, you know? I've I've always
heard things about them." You know? And
so I went to go just go ask just to talk
to them a little bit. And they told me
how like Jesus is not God. But at first
they sounded like they talked very
similar to you know, the language that I
used as a Christian. Like, "Yeah, we
believe in Jesus and we believe in in
God and the son of God and stuff like
that." And so what's really deceptive is
they use what famous word Christianese,
right? They use words that we use, but
they mean the opposite thing. And so I
got I got by Jehovah's Witnesses, man. I
I thought that, you know, you know, at
the time like, "Yeah, Jesus is God."
They showed me Colossians 1:15. You
know, I had no answer. I didn't have the
awareness to read continue reading the
next verse. You know, that says that uh
you know, Jesus, you know, created all
things and is before all things. So at
the time I'm like, "Man, he got me." He
put his hand on my shoulder and said,
"Yeah, you you got to do some research,
man. You got to do some homework." You
know? I never wanted to feel that again.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. Ever again,
Mike. And so
>> I got to call I called my dad like,
"Man, where's where does the Bible say
Jesus is God?" He's like, "Man, John 1
and you know, John 10:30." I'm like,
"Oh, see, duh." You know? But ever since
then I'm like, "Man, I'm not equipped."
And like I'm a youth leader at the time
in my dad's church. So I know my peers
aren't equipped cuz we're like at the
top. Yeah. You know, we're equally
acknowledged and some like, man, that
means that a bunch of Christians out
there are not equipped to deal with
these cults and deal with this falsehood
that's out here facing them. So, I'm
like, that's when basically God Logic
was born, you know, and the ministry
started, you know, and so it's been it's
been up from there, man.
>> That's awesome, man. So, wait, which
groups do you focus on the most? Is it
Is it Islam the most?
>> It's Islam the most. Second would
probably be Hebrew Israelites. Okay. And
like kind of a a tie like with
Unitarians just in general.
>> Yeah. Now, do you think the Hebrew
Israelites, they were like growing leaps
and bounds 5 years ago, 6 years ago?
Are they still like
>> no, not as fast as they as they were.
They they were explosive at one point,
but it's it's not the cuz information
has been out there, you know? Like
people have People are learning the
arguments, they're learning what they do
and what they say, and so now people
aren't so caught off guard anymore, you
know?
>> know guys like Vocabmalone has done a
lot of work on this He's the go-to. To
this day, he is my I got videos
downloaded for him. Yeah. When it comes
to Hebrew Israelites, so he's the go-to
guy. Check out Vocabmalone, guys, if you
want to get into Hebrew Israelism. But,
yeah, they're they're not growing as
fast. It's, you know, it's it's kind of
like with Islam. Islam was exploding for
a while, too, you know, but
>> the internet
the internet happened. And so now people
know about Muhammad and Aisha. They know
about the Islamic dilemma, you know,
they know about these things, and so
it's not as easy to fool people as much
as it was
10 years ago, 50 years ago.
>> Westerners were just like
putty in the hands of Muslims because
we've like been trained by media to like
think they're basically Christians, but
you know, more noble. My gosh, bro.
That's [laughter] kind of the idea.
>> It's insane, man.
>> every every film, you know, I remember
watching [laughter]
So, so I'm going to date myself here. I
remember watching this Kevin Costner
Robin Hood movie.
And the it was this noble Muslim
character that was in the film. And it
wasn't just that he was noble. Nothing's
wrong with that, right? No, no. It was
that Islam was noble.
That was the message, right? It was
Islam is noble, you know? And then you
have these corrupt Christians that are
the backdrop of like the king and all
this
So I just I we we've seen this for
years. So they were just like completely
unaware. They assumed that all the
religions are similar to Christianity.
That's a That's a general American view.
Oh, they're all kind of similar, right?
>> Yeah. And they don't realize like, dude,
Islam is like
you're going to die. Mhm. You're dead,
dude.
>> Yeah.
This is This is you you don't understand
what you're messing with. Like you need
to understand he was a warlord. I mean,
you know this stuff far better than I
do. Warlord, I'll say it. Warlord,
womanizer,
uh uh freak,
money launderer,
caravan robber. Yeah, all of that.
Pagan, heretic.
Evil evil dude. Yeah, sick.
Yeah. So
it's really great to get that
information out there because I've been
thinking about this like
the things that Okay, so you mentioned
cults, but religion-wise, right? Islam,
Buddhism, Hinduism, I feel like
Christians have like barely started.
Yes. And that we need in this social
media world, we need like
not only Islam as you you you know,
there's some guys who've done really
good work and done a lot. Yourself,
David Wood. There's other guys who've
been like
hammering this for a long time. And I'm
really grateful for
um and I if I had more hours in the day,
I'd be right now preparing content on
Hinduism. Because I'm like, dude, are we
>> Nobody's doing doing that.
>> Nobody's doing it. No one is doing it.
real content. Like you know the
religion. You understand it. And it's
And this is a complicated one cuz
Hinduism's it's not one like Islam is
one religion. Hinduism is like a
thousand religions that got smashed and
glued together.
>> Wow. And it's really confusing and weird
and and then Buddhism yeah, with all its
branches.
>> Dude, I'm telling you, man. I I've
looked up stuff when it comes to like
Hinduism and, you know, versus
Christianity type of thing hoping to
find, you know, some Christian apologist
that, yeah, deals or specializes in
those categories. There's nothing. I
haven't seen anything.
>> It's wild, and I'm just thinking, dude,
how many Hindus are there in the world?
Let's just say it's more than there are
Mormons,
more than there are Jehovah's Witnesses,
more than there are fill in the blank,
any cult you've ever heard of. And they
need to be evangelized, and the internet
is an amazing way to do that.
>> Absolutely.
>> stuff on them, and you do it smart.
>> Yeah.
>> And you do it right. It doesn't have to
be me, it doesn't have to be you
necessarily, but we need like somebody
out there, you're watching, man.
>> Yes. Become the Hindu apologist
Christian who you you you you know the
religion back and forward, and you
evangelize these guys, and you use
debate to do it. That'd be awesome.
>> You know what? I I when I think about
it, it seems like
like Jehovah's Witnesses, Mormons,
Islam, um
uh the Mother God cult, it's it's like
these guys are targeted by Christians
because of the Bible, and the like all
of these cults speak on the Bible or
claim some have some type of claims
for and against the Bible, right? So,
it's like it's it's easier for
Christians to Wait, what? I know the
Bible. Let me go at you, know, and and
go at that. But Hinduism and Buddhism is
completely separate from Christian like
they have no connection whatsoever. They
don't claim us. They don't claim our
book. They don't really claim Jesus like
that, not really, you know, so yeah,
it's it's like completely like
uh new ground.
>> it's foreign territory.
>> Yeah, foreign territory.
>> Yeah, you're you're like, "Okay, so
how many
Hindus know what's in the Bhagavad Gita?
Do they read it?
>> Yeah. How strictly do they believe their
doctrines? Like I, you know,
Christianity is a very much like
doctrine-based religion. Um but for a
lot of Hindus and and even a lot of
Buddhists, it's really not.
>> Yeah. It's interesting.
>> else, you know, and you're like, "Oh,
it's almost like it's more tradition."
You know, there's there's some of these
Buddhists like burning the the hell
notes at the at the grave going, if
someone goes like what do you what does
this mean? They'd be like
I don't know. Yeah. That's hilarious. I
don't know what [laughter] I'm doing.
And so it can be and there's others who
very much know of course, but but you so
when you like to develop strategies.
Like for instance, you guys have a
strategy. It's and it's a strategy.
You're like let's hammer this Aisha
thing. Right? Muhammad
married a six-year-old girl and by their
own sources slept with her when she was
nine years old. Okay? We're going to
hammer this. We're going to hammer it
over and over again because this is
going to be the thing that opens the
door to the Muslim beginning to think
maybe I'll listen to that gospel thing
you're talking about.
>> Yeah.
>> So we need strategies like simple
strategies like that for Hindu, for
Buddhism. And I genuinely don't know
them. Yeah. Right? Like I can talk about
karma. I can talk I can talk about the
gospel. But what you find is that
by targeting a weakness in the false
religion, you open the door to that
gospel being heard, right?
>> Um so yeah, we need that.
>> Yeah, I agree. So now, one last thing
for folks who are up and coming
who are aspiring to
uh you know, reach the level of teaching
that you're at content-wise, you know,
just there's there's a lot of explosive
young adults and youth that are on fire
for God right now. The Christian wave on
the internet is killing it right now.
What would you give as some advice or
just word of encouragement for those up
and coming aspiring content creators,
Christian Christian content creators?
>> Yeah. Oh yeah. I'll spill out some
things real quick. Yes, yes. Go ahead
and drop it on them. Number one, man. Uh
it don't know what you don't know. Mhm.
>> Just stick to what you know. Don't know
what you don't know. That's fine. Just
be that way. Acknowledge that.
There's some questions you can't answer,
things you That's just be safe with
that. Um study the Bible a lot. Yeah.
Like especially if you want to be
teaching the word, study it a lot. Don't
just repeat your favorite teacher,
including me if that's me for some
reason.
Don't just repeat it like get in the
word. In fact, in your Bible studies go
study the Bible without all the helps.
Get your understanding of a passage,
then come in with the commentaries. And
then it this trains you to become a
better Bible study person. It's like
really good. Um I'd also say um
do what you're good at, not just what
you see other people doing. And really
lean on your gifts. Like what What am I
What comes easy to me that's hard for
someone else? And lean in on that
because I know for me, I tried copying
on YouTube what I saw other YouTubers
doing. And when I entered YouTube it was
the land of zany videos, you know? So I
tried some like weird zany things and
I'd bring a a Bible thing into it and it
was like it didn't work.
And I finally was like, you know, I'm
just I'm just good at teaching.
And long-form videos on YouTube, nobody
If it's longer than 4 minutes at the
time.
So but I was like, but this is all this
is what I'm good at, you know? So I'm
just going to lean into that. And then
over time I learned how to do that
better for YouTube.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> Um and then it started slowly getting
traction, but I'm just suggesting
whatever you're good at, do that. Are
you good at the comedy? Are you good Are
you just like you're that sarcastic
hilarious dude? Are you like the
information guy? Are you like the guy
that like zeros in on exactly Or you
maybe you're you're the person who uh
you hold someone's hand and you help
them through what they're going through
in their life, you know? And you're like
that. Maybe you're the motherly figure
or the sister who comes alongside.
Lean in on whatever you are because if
you prioritize what you're good at,
forget viral anything.
I'm saying just help people. Just say,
"I'm good at this and I can actually
help people with it." And then the views
and stuff will take care of themselves.
Because when people find real value in
your content, you don't have to
use gimmicks Yeah. and tricks.
>> You don't got to be something you're
not. Yeah, cuz their their life is being
impacted by it because you're doing what
you're good at. You're ministering to
them. Like you're using the gifts God
gives you and you're pouring them out.
Exactly. Well, that was Mike Winger,
man. Thank you so much for sitting down
with me, bro.
>> Thank you for having me.
>> One of my dreams. So you helped me, man.
You helped me a lot. God bless you guys,
man. Stay tuned on the next one.
It's God. [music]
It's God.
>> [singing]
>> It's God.